estas son las dos formas que te vas a
encontrar de cómo se define la derivada
en términos del límite
generalmente usamos esta definición si
estamos pensando en la derivada en un
punto y generalmente usamos esta forma
cuando estamos pensando en la derivada
en general para cualquier punto x pero
en realidad estas dos definiciones son
equivalentes las dos están describiendo
la pendiente de la línea tangente y
también la tasa de cambio instantáneo y
ahora usando estas definiciones quiero
establecer las propiedades básicas de
las derivadas la primera propiedad que
vamos a ver puede llegar a parecer que
es algo como sentido común por lo menos
una vez que la veamos así se va a sentir
pero esta propiedad nos dice que si una
función f de x es igual a una constante
entonces
efe prima de x es igual a 0
porque esto podría ser sentido común
bueno para que veas que si es algo como
sentido común vamos a graficar lo este
es el eje y este es el eje x ese eje x
xi gráfica mos fx igual a la constante
que se ve así donde este es el valor de
igual acá y esta es la gráfica de igual
a fx y aquí
obsérvalo fijamente no importa cómo
vamos a x ya no cambia la pendiente de
la recta tangente bueno de hecho la
tangente es la misma recta no importa
cuánto cambie x sigue teniendo el mismo
valor no cambia nada la pendiente es
igual a 0 y no cambia nunca no importa
cuánto cambie x y bueno de hecho podemos
utilizar cualquiera de estas dos
definiciones para establecerlo
formalmente y es lo que vamos a hacer
es que ponemos por aquí el límite cuando
h tiende a cero de f de x + h pero sin
importar qué valor tengamos aquí efe
siempre es igual a la constante k así es
que aquí tenemos f x + h igual acá - efe
x pero otra vez no importa en qué valor
evaluemos a efe siempre nos da acá y eso
lo estamos dividiendo entre h ahora esto
de aquí es simplemente cero así es que
aquí tenemos 0 / h por lo que este
límite es igual a 0 así es que f prima
de x para cualquier valor de x es igual
a cero y eso es justo lo que estábamos
viendo por aquí la pendiente de la recta
tangente que es esta misma recta para
cualquier valor de x la pendiente es 0
así es que si vas muy feliz campante por
la calle y alguien llega y te dice oye
si tienes una función f
que evaluada en x es igual a pi cuál es
la derivada de f
bueno pues tú en ese momento dices ok y
es una constante entonces
efe prima de x la derivada de una
función que es constante la tasa de
cambio instantáneo de una constante la
pendiente de la recta tangente de una
función constante o la tasa de cambio
instantáneo de una constante eso siempre
es igual a cero